a season pass for final fantasy 15 has
been listed on the North American and
Japanese PlayStation stores revealing
details and the extra content that will
be available for Square Enix as RPG I'm
Dave and welcome to our chocobos at the
ready news update although it hasn't
been revealed how much the DLC s will
cost individually or even what they
include their names allow for some
educated guesses at least three other
packs seems we story episodes based
around Ignace Gladio and Prompto three
of the game's main characters in
addition to these there is a booster
pack a holiday pack and an expansion
pack although it's unclear exactly what
these are at the moment the season pass
is included in the digital premium
edition of final fantasy 15 which is
available to pre-order 480 $4.99 on the
PlayStation Store an upgrade option is
also available as a special deal to
those who have already pre-ordered a
digital version of the game it is
initially listed for $24.99 final
fantasy 15 is scheduled for release on
September 30th 2016 for PlayStation 4
and Xbox one
although Square Enix is thinking about a
PC version but if the RPG does come to
PC fans should not expect it to launch
alongside the console editions in
September so are you looking forward to
final fantasy 15
let us know in the comments section
below or find me on Twitter at irregular
Dave and for all your final fantasy news
stay tuned to games for calm